cela demande du temps.
Quand on regarde les données,
Il semble qu'Einstein avec sa recherche de génie ait eu raison,
et je suis à ce stade de ma carrière.
(Rires)
On s'est dit : « Ok, on va voir comment cela se produit vraiment,
d'abord en science. »
Et pour ne pas avoir un a priori sur la sélection,
pas seulement les génies,
on a fini par retracer la carrière de chaque scientifique
de 1900 à aujourd'hui
et trouver pour chacun d'entre eux quel était leur record personnel,
qu'ils aient obtenu un prix Nobel ou pas,
ou que personne ne sache ce qu'ils ont fait, même leur record personnel.
C'est que l'on voit sur cette diapositive.
Chaque ligne est une carrière,
et quand il y a un point bleu clair au-dessus de cette carrière,
cela indique le record personnel.
Et la question est :
quand ont-ils vraiment fait leur plus grande découverte ?
Pour quantifier cela,
on se demande quelle est la probabilité de faire sa plus grande découverte,
après 1, 2, 3 ou 10 années d'expérience ?
Nous ne regardons pas leur vrai âge,
mais « l'âge académique ».
Votre âge académique commence lorsque vous publiez vos premiers articles.
Je sais que certains d'entre vous sont encore des bébés.
(Rires)
Regardons donc la probabilité
que vous publiiez votre article avec le plus gros impact.
Et on voit que la recherche sur les génies est en effet vraie.
La plupart des scientifiques publient leur article le plus impactant
dans les 10 à 15 premières années de leur carrière,
puis ça chute.
Ça chute si vite que j'en suis presque -- j'en suis exactement à 30 ans de carrière,
et la chance que je publie un article qui aura un plus fort impact
que tout ce que j'ai déjà fait avant
est de moins de 1%.
J'en suis à ce stade de ma carrière, selon ces données.
Mais il y a un problème avec ça.
C'est que nous ne faisons pas les contrôles correctement.
Le contrôle serait :
à quoi ressemble un scientifique qui apporte aléatoirement à la science ?
Ou quelle est la productivité de ce scientifique ?
Quand écrivent-ils les articles ?
Donc nous avons mesuré la productivité,
et étonnamment, la productivité,
votre probabilité de rédiger un article la 1ère, 10ème ou 20ème année de carrière,
est indissociable de la probabilité d’avoir un impact
sur cette partie de votre carrière.
Et pour faire court,
après plusieurs tests statistiques, il n'y a qu'une explication :
la façon dont nous, scientifiques, travaillons,
est que chaque article écrit, chaque projet effectué,
a exactement la même chance de devenir notre record personnel.
Que la découverte est comme un ticket de loterie.
Et plus nous achetons de tickets,
plus nous avons de chances.
Et il en résulte
que la plupart des scientifiques achètent leurs tickets de loterie
dans les 10 ou 15 premières années de leur carrière,
et après cela, leur productivité diminue.
Ils n'achètent plus de tickets.
Il semblerait donc qu'ils ne soient plus créatifs.
En réalité, ils ont arrêté d'essayer.
Donc quand on rassemble les données, la conclusion est très simple :
le succès peut arriver à tout moment.
Ça peut être le tout premier ou le dernier article de votre carrière.
C'est totalement aléatoire dans l'espace des projets.
C'est la productivité qui change.
Laissez-moi illustrer ça.
Voici Frank Wilczek, qui a reçu le Prix Nobel de Physique
pour le premier article qu'il a écrit - il était encore étudiant.
(Rires)
Plus intéressant encore, John Fenn,
qui à 70 ans, a été forcé de prendre sa retraite par l'Université de Yale.
Ils ont fermé son laboratoire,
et à ce moment, il a déménagé à la Virginia Commonwealth University,
a ouvert un nouveau laboratoire,
et c'est là, à 72 ans, qu'il a publié un article
pour lequel, 15 ans plus tard, il a reçu le Prix Nobel de Chimie.
Et vous vous dites : « OK, le domaine des sciences est spécial,
mais qu'en est-il des autres domaines où il faut être créatif ? »
Prenons un autre exemple : l'entrepreneuriat.
La Silicon Valley,
la terre de la jeunesse, n'est-ce pas ?
En effet, quand on s'y intéresse,
on réalise que les plus grands prix, le Prix du TechCrunch et d'autres,
reviennent tous à des gens
dont l'âge moyen varie entre la fin de vingtaine et le début de la trentaine.
Si vous regardez à qui les plus gros investisseurs donnent :
que des personnes au début de la trentaine.
Ce que, bien sûr, nous savons :
il y a une philosophie là-bas qui fait que jeunesse rime avec succès.
Pas quand on regarde les données,
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas que de créer une entreprise -
créer une entreprise, c'est comme la productivité, toujours essayer -
quand vous regardez lequel de ces individus a effectivement lancé
une entreprise prospère, une sortie réussie.
Récemment, certains de nos collègues se sont posé la même question.
Et il s'avère que oui, les personnes entre 20 et 30 ans
ont lancé un grand nombre d'entreprises, créé beaucoup d'entreprises,
mais la plupart ont fait faillite.
Et quand on regarde les sorties réussies, ce que l'on voit dans ce graphique,
plus vous êtes âgé, plus vous avez de chances de réussir en bourse
ou de vendre l’entreprise avec succès.
En fait, c'est tellement fort que si vous avez la cinquantaine,
vous avez deux fois plus de chance d’avoir une sortie réussie
que si vous êtes dans la trentaine.
(Applaudissements)
Finalement, qu'est-ce que l'on voit ?
Ce que l'on voit, c'est que la créativité n'a pas d'âge.
Mais la productivité si, d'accord ?
Ce qui me fait dire que finalement,
si vous poursuivez vos efforts --
(Rires)
vous pouvez toujours connaître le succès, encore et encore.
Donc ma conclusion est très simple :
je quitte la scène, direction mon labo.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)